i think that we have to get into our
conspiracy bag right here
uh we've got some big things going on uh
we have gillay maxwell
yep um
is guilty on five of six accounts yeah
do we think that people will feel
satisfied by this decision
um
kind of sorta i think okay i think
people will be satisfied that like there
is like some semblance of justice that
it's not just like
covered up oh epstein killed himself
that kind of [ __ ] yeah but ultimately
and i think you were mentioned this
yesterday
gillane isn't the person that people
want to see even if she is the
ringleader the head of the whole thing
the most responsible yeah
they want to see the people that are
related and around the case yeah that's
what i fear about this right now is like
[Music]
there's a very good chance that they
didn't really have any good intelligence
or like proof of kid [ __ ] from all
these uh elites and politicians that
were on the island or on the plane right
there's a very good chance right we've
all
i've i think like gone down the rabbit
hole and started to believe that they
did and they got these tapes and they
have this advanced recording system it
is america it is upper upper east side
apartment and then the island they
recorded everything and there's a kill
switch in case someone dies
and like i think we all start to believe
it because
we wanted
the the other bad guys like we wanted
the clintons and we wanted the uh bill
gates and we wanted uh who else is on
there
uh who else has been uh prince andrew
alan dershowitz like we wanted these
guys that we already didn't like yeah
because of their [ __ ] up actions and
behaviors we wanted them to go down and
we're like oh here's a tool for you guys
to go down
right so now we have this tool this tool
for you guys to go down is gelane
maxwell and jeffrey epstein and their
child sex ring that they took part in
right so i think a lot of people acted
like they cared so much about pedophilia
when really they're just using the child
sex ring to take down their bad guys
right which is ironically the same thing
that epstein and gillane were doing is
using child sex trafficking to take down
their enemies right right or to uh what
is it a flip or get the loyalty of right
uh certain people right so that they
could control certain people yeah so i'm
just thinking like
i think the average person if you ask
them can you name two people that
epstein or galen touched or diddled or
sold into sex trafficking i don't think
they'd be able no chance i can't and
there was a whole documentary and i
can't either i know virginia guffray and
then it stops right there so we can't
really care that much about the victims
if we don't even know who the victims
are
right selfishly maybe we care more about
the people that we kind of don't like
getting punished and this is the method
of punishment maybe we just selfishly
want what we feel like is justice we
feel like we feel like it's just okay i
feel like powerful people get away with
everything we don't get away with [ __ ]
we lie on our taxes the [ __ ]
government throws us in jail they lie on
their taxes they do whatever they want
yeah they don't pay taxes jeff bezos
don't ever have to pay anything so you
want some form of justice and especially
if they're doing something this vile
yeah i want justice yeah so this excites
us because it might bring justice but if
this is where it stops we'll forget
about it yeah but it's not satisfying i
wonder if like
we even get confused with the word
justice right because like i don't think
that humans have ever wanted justice in
terms of like the justice system like
somebody kills your daughter and then
they go to jail for life i don't think
you feel okay with that uh
that is justice in terms of justice
system but real justice is some
hammurabi's code [ __ ] yeah real justice
like you killed my daughter i'ma kill
you yeah you're lucky i will kill your
daughter so you know what it feels like
yeah and i think that
human beings get caught up in this
concept of like let's call it instead of
justice like even because that's where
our emotional feelings are like that's
that was the [ __ ] oj [ __ ] like the oj
thing was
people wanted o.j to get off not because
they liked doj but because they were
like why people be getting off yeah yeah
and you know what
i don't know
ron or nicole
serial killers
or terrorists we want them to get put
behind bars because they could affect
our lives still right
oj was upset someone was smashing his
wife
he ain't gonna come kill my wife he's
done kill it right right like he's a
monster to one person huh now two people
he was a monster to one person then a
second person yes that's not that but
this is a monster to any random person
i'm any random person
i'm not a wife i'm not a guy [ __ ] a
wife i'm a random person that's what
serial killers going after lock that guy
up so i feel safe exactly so it's just
like let's have it just kind of be eve
it's the same it's the kyle rin how [ __ ]
it was like it's how do we make this
even if this was a black kid he would
have been shot or he would have been put
in jail for what he did what would be
even is if he got shot or put in jail
that would be even
right like it's people it's people
trying to like right the scale instead
of going to like what the justice system
requires right
that's kind of what i believe yeah i
agree with you but i do think that there
is a
sense of justice when someone goes away
to jail even if it's even if like they
committed murder yeah and we don't kill
them because it's like if um
what's the dude who stepped on
uh put his needs uh george floyd uh
if chauvin didn't go to jail that's no
justice you're right i feel there was
justice that his life got taken away
from him like in terms of career
everything and he's going to jail for a
long time you're right yeah i wouldn't
want to see him killed yeah it's not uh
it's
to use a shitty uh
example black or white
like it's not black or white there is
a semblance of justice or or getting
even in seeing someone convicted there's
no question like um
[Music]
yeah like that's a perfect example or
even like one of these like scumbag
businessmen or like a pharmaceutical guy
like ends up going away for a long time
because he was you know pumping a bad
drug you're like i feel like there's a
little bit of justice here especially
from us on the outside you know but i
imagine george floyd's family is like
kill that [ __ ] so justice maybe
is more emotional vindication like i
feel vindicated that you went to jail
for what you did it doesn't have to be
even but you need to [ __ ] go to jail
for what you did that's [ __ ] crazy
there's also a difference between like
placating the society and the people
that were like directly agree effective
but then the most indication is kill
that [ __ ] are you talking about
this but then should those people are
the ones that write laws for what
justice is you know what i mean like
because obviously the person that's
aggrieved is going to be the most
emotional about it and you don't want
the biggest punishment yeah is that
going to be the thing that actually like
satisfies society and what allows
society to function in the most normal
and safe way yeah because if we just
start chopping off legs because somebody
you know hit you in a car and you had to
get your leg chopped off [ __ ] could get
wild out here
right i mean there's a reason probably
why they moved away from the hammer
obvious coach [ __ ] yeah
it is interesting i just one what
happens to the people that have the
blood lust for galen and epstein like
what happens when they find out that
that bloodlust was really for the elites
or do you think they've already
understood that and reconciled that and
they knew that they were like kind of
being phony and caring about these uh
women or young girls who are child sex
trafficked
um
i think it's kind of both yeah that's
what i would say just because you don't
necessarily know the victim or like
identify with them i don't know if this
really means you don't care about
them or like the justice system
operating on a functional level right
yeah i mean like if i see a random dude
get punched in time square like i don't
know that guy and also don't really like
care about him right but the guy that
punched him i'm like i hope like
something bad happens to him yeah that's
just like i don't want him to just be
walking around yeah partially for fear
that someone could just punch me but
like that fear could also play in with
kids random kids getting scooped up and
taking them out oh yeah i got kids but
if it's not him that you know gets
arrested like the fact that you could
just do that to someone and nothing
happens to you that's terrifying that
affects everything yeah yeah it's
unsettling like what society do we live
in where somebody can you know traffic
children and then nothing happens yeah
exactly yeah so many people have kids
like the majority of people have kids
and then the powers that be
even if they're involved in it have a
responsibility to like maintain the calm
of society
so
let's say that there's the powers to be
let's just say the conspirators are true
and the upper echelon of society was you
know orchestrating this ring so that
they could uh you know get information
on these certain people and then
manipulate them to their will right
let's say but once you start to see
people go yo we're not cool with you
guys letting child [ __ ] off yeah
and there's enough unrest within society
you gotta either kill epstein or you
gotta lock up gillane just so we're all
calm right cause we're gonna start
acting wild out here if you're just
letting people [ __ ] kids and get away
with it yeah that's what i was gonna say
it's like i think if she got off you
would have saw how much people care
like there'd be protests like there'd be
a hole this [ __ ] would've went off if
she got off yeah but the fact that she
was guilty on basically everything it's
like all right finally what we thought
was going to happen happened
and i think people care a little bit
less mind you they're both disgusting
it's a little less icky when it's a
woman well you're little girls
it's
yo it is true it is true less icky
yeah it is true yeah and i wonder if
women also feel that i think so
like you think girls are also like it's
a little bit less yeah also we don't
know as much about galena what she did
versus with epstein right we know
epstein was like yo [ __ ] jerk me jerk
me off like i'm gonna have sex with you
all that [ __ ] yeah and yeah i think that
that point's true like it's
psychologically way weirder when it's a
guy yeah you're more disturbing it's
more gross it's more vile yeah
when it's a girl
even though i feel she might have been
worse because she was the one grooming
them getting them comfortable logically
yes
but it doesn't hit you here the same
thing yeah
yeah so then her brother comes out and
says she's not gonna reveal any of the
details of those involved in the sex
trafficking network in exchange for like
a plea deal or a more lenient sentence
this just happened this is like over the
weekend yeah okay yeah wow so he comes
out and says that so now people are
speculating like okay is he saying that
so first off she didn't say anything
beforehand because my understanding is
that if she
says i'm innocent i had nothing to do
with this i was a victim but here's who
actually did it that it could
potentially implicate her
more directly in the crimes that oh you
knew about all this and didn't say
anything earlier blah blah blah and that
she was maintaining her her innocence
she's like i'm totally ah that's
interesting so you're saying she's
saying i'm totally in a sense
she can't have information since she's
totally interested once she gives
information she's an accessory to the
crime then she can be convicted on yeah
even just accessory [ __ ] like that yeah
but she was trying to get nothing and
then now that she has
all these charges
right before sentencing it's like okay
does she come out and now rat on people
her brother's saying no and people are
assuming like if epstein got killed
she could easily get killed
okay here we go okay because this is
what i didn't understand i was asking
you guys on the phone yesterday i was
like why didn't she squeal she has all
the leverage to get the deal before
she's convicted now that she's convicted
she got no leverage that's if they have
an amazing case against you like if you
are like in a gang and they find you
with like weapons and they like can
place you out of murder then it's in
your best interest to be like
all right give me the plea i did this
[ __ ] but like and i know they're gonna
get me because they got all this
evidence i'm assuming that her legal
team was like they don't have enough
evidence on them oh so they thought that
they had a shot of beating it yeah so
like keep your mouth shut until it
happens and then right before sentencing
if you're gonna do something to it then
we got the plea in the back pocket
so now what they're gonna do is go back
and they're gonna say listen we got all
these [ __ ] people yeah i was involved
you were right you got me boom but i'm
gonna drop diamond all these
[ __ ] so now they're reaching
out to the powers-to-be and they're
saying hey how sweet a deal can you get
me before everybody knows you [ __ ]
children that's if she wants to put her
life at risk
because if epstein got killed she can
get killed yeah but don't you think
they're gonna kill this [ __ ] regardless
now
if the brother is coming out immediately
saying hey she's not going to tell them
everybody knows it's a chance to kill
her oh so she's putting out the
smoke signal
you're safe and not only should you not
kill me get me out of here
like i'm going to get 20 years but
you're tight with the da or whatever
like get me out of good behavior in 10.
eight and we don't even got to make a
big thing of it give me the [ __ ] 20
years yeah i'll be out in 10 some people
talk about it but by then there'll be
other [ __ ] going on
let me live oh [ __ ]
i think her hardest decision was not
naming names beforehand because like you
said she had the most leverage she could
have probably worked a deal out where
she could have got immunity even if
she's admitting to being an accomplice
to it she could have got immunity
but
they would have probably killed her
being outside now she has to be look
over her shoulder for the rest of her
life so she's like hey i'll just take
these years i'll do the time i'm gonna
keep my mouth shut and then you guys
make sure you get me out a little bit
earlier and and i know we've spoken
about before but a lot of people believe
that her father who was a spy for i
think the israeli i'm sorry government
was uh they thought
right and uh was killed they say was
killed he fell off a boat or something
like that so she knows it could happen
her boy her husband jeffrey epstein like
yeah in jail he gets killed
i don't know if he was kill mark i think
he committed suicide yeah yeah on
suicide watching
make these claims mark yeah like what
evidence do you have to back that dude
that's a good point
sleepy guards
okay uh yeah
so the thing that i'm almost curious
about with her is
if because people speculate that she and
epstein were working for a government
so like
working with saudis working with mossad
working for the u.s government yeah like
was it just him as like a stand-alone
operator trying to like gain money and
influence was he working in conjunction
with
like a bigger institution
interesting and if she goes out and rats
and is like yo the saudis put me up to
it
like because epstein apparently had like
a fake saudi passport like in his house
or whatever
so if all of a sudden she says that like
does that create bigger geopolitical
yeah we gotta go to war
well that's the thing why you might need
to keep that [ __ ] in the tuck
because it might be better
globally for us that's where the
government's got to go yeah do we
like do we push her to squeal
and then
that potentially makes us look like
[ __ ] idiots that we got had by all
these other governments yeah or do we
just say it was just her and epstein
keep it quiet
and then try to give her a deal later
that's the um
that's the thing with uh jfk's murder or
assassination like some people believe
it was the russians
and it's better for our history
russia didn't kill a president yeah
people say trump got elected because of
russian interference right it's like
even if they were buying facebook ads or
whatever which i think is like
completely possible yeah people were
saying like yeah we just gotta say no
it's better for our history yeah that
that didn't happen because we can't make
it look like these other countries are
one killing a head of state like that's
you've got to go to war for that yeah
like that is war guaranteed and we have
nukes and they have nukes so it's going
to get messy
so that's why you've got to keep it
quiet so if they find out it's saudi or
they find out israeli then we have to
have like back channel conversations
maybe it's russian whatever who the [ __ ]
knows we look weak just getting oil
getting trade deals again all that [ __ ]
interest maybe it's china who [ __ ]
knows but we got to find that out under
the table
for our respect globally yeah
interesting yeah
and if people believe that all these u.s
officials are compromised like how can
you operate in good faith with all these
other governments being like yeah
we're sending hillary clinton to go do
this deal like what do they have on her
right yeah
can she even negotiate with the head of
russia did she even negotiate with any
of these countries
interesting i mean who's even looking
into this how do we know the people
looking into this aren't as equally
corrupted
yeah this is messy and sad when when you
think about just like
it's just sad the whole thing is just
sad yeah the action is sad the fact
there's not gonna be any real like stop
to it or justice probably that's sad
it's just a sad [ __ ] thing
it feels a bit hopeless yeah her husband
jumped out
really yeah maxwell had a husband and
she just he just left it just now just
now for like the pilates instructor or
something yeah
yeah that's a win that's a win bro
that's a win i mean he stayed with her
through this whole thing yeah
that's wild
he must have believed it yeah or thought
that he would she would kill his ass
well she's about to be free yeah like if
he got off now he could leave you for
the pilates instructor because you can't
do nothing you locked up [ __ ] right
like what you're going
exactly figure your [ __ ] out yeah damn
he did it over the phone too well i mean
you can't go there yeah come on
face behind the glasses even if it's
face to face is over a phone yes yeah
[ __ ] all that i'm doing a
that breaking up in person [ __ ] for who
why we've been wasting both of our times
i could write you a letter [ __ ] you're
lucky i called you yeah it won't make it
any better no girl's more happy cause
you did in person
i should have like press one for this
collection
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you